[Music]
when disney fans think jungle cruise
they think riding around in boats
fascinating animals
and funny dad jokes galore all that can
be found in disney's new film based on
the ride
but there's also so much more he has
everything only adults are likely to
notice in disney's jungle cruise
adults who remember the music of the
early 1990s will be surprised when they
immediately recognize the first few
notes
of the ballad that opens jungle cruise
no that song wasn't composed
specifically for the film
it's the instrumental to power ballad
nothing else matters which was released
by metallica in 1991 and has since
become a staple of the band's live shows
and one of its most recognizable songs
according to the credits of jungle
cruise metallica reimagined nothing else
matters with the film's composer james
newton howard
and the four current members of the band
james hedfield
lars ulrich kirk hammett and robert
trujiho are listed as featured
performers on the movies version of the
song
the ballads haunting melancholy quality
makes it especially recognizable
and while the melody is lovely it's not
clear why howard decided to feature an
orchestral version of a hit from the 90s
in the film
in fact for those in the know the
inclusion of nothing else matters may be
downright distracting
especially given the movie takes place
in 1916
and otherwise features an entirely
original score on the other hand it
could also serve as a good excuse to
introduce kids to metallica
from a bus full of soldiers to german
u-boats historical references abound in
jungle cruise
however unless they're exceptionally
young history buffs kids are unlikely to
be familiar with the film's numerous
nods to world war one
after all while world war ii's nazis
remain popular film and tv villains it's
much rarer for germans from world war
one to be astori's antagonist
as is the case with jesse plemons
villanus prince wakeem in jungle cruise
part of lillian mcgregor halton's
argument for going after the tears of
the moon
is that it could revolutionize medicine
by healing british and
other allied soldiers who were even more
likely to die of disease in the trenches
than they were to be killed by the
germans
the film also references kaiser wilhelm
ii
the last emperor of germany who
abdicated his throne upon losing the war
in 1918.
however even adults may not know that
wilhelm's youngest son
really was named joakim as far as we
know though the real-life prince were
keem
never took a u-boat of the amazon to
search for a legendary tree
throughout the movie lily encounters
more than her fair share of overt sexism
she's first introduced in the balcony of
a theater where her brother is
presenting a speech she clearly wrote to
an academic guild made up entirely of
men
and even though she has a phd her
knowledge and abilities are often
questioned
as is her resolve to go after the tears
of the moon even her brother worries
about it would take care of her if she
went to the amazon alone
although she's clearly more than capable
of taking care of herself
in addition her choice to wear pants a
rarity in 1916 is called out repeatedly
frank finds her choice to be so
exceptional that he even gives her the
nickname
pants kids these days may be surprised
by the treatments the obviously smart
and determined lily endures
adults however will know quite well that
blatant discrimination against women was
more or less the global standard
making her the story's underdog just by
being a woman
soon after frank and lily first meet
frank is revealed to have lied to her
about his true identity
however he regains her confidence when
he goes up against the jaguar who
menaces the patrons at the restaurant
where they're dining
after all if frank can take on a jaguar
he's certainly capable of taking over up
the amazon
careful they could smell fear however
lily missed one thing
jaguars and other animals are unlikely
to attack humans unless they've been
directly threatened
which this jaguar clearly was not as a
result many adults in the audience may
realize that since the jaguar wasn't
acting in self-defense
it's unclear why it came into the
restaurant much less attacked the large
gathering of people there
given the fear and adrenaline lily might
have felt in that moment
she seems to have failed to notice that
given those variables while frank's
ability to wrestle the jaguar seemed
impressive
something else was clearly going on and
indeed the movie soon reveals that frank
and the jaguar who's named proxima are
in cahoots
with proxima attacking frank in order to
secure him the job as lily skipper
early in their trip down the amazon
frank's boat of akilah sails past a part
of long peaked dolphins that all bear
little resemblance to the bottlenose
dolphins
many people are most familiar with
however adults may be aware that there
are numerous dolphin species
and one of them is the amazon river
dolphin shown in the movie
this freshwater dolphin is native to the
amazon and is also sometimes referred to
as the pink river dolphin
or in brazil the buttercutter rosa due
to its pinkish hue
in the movie lily refers to the dolphins
by their scientific name
inia jeffrensis meanwhile frank's
identification
of them as encantado evokes a myth about
amazon river dolphins being
shapeshifters
and more broadly refers to the many
other legends surrounding the species
including the one frank relates that
looking into a pink river dolphins eyes
will lead to a lifetime
of nightmares almost 20 years ago
another movie inspired by a boat-based
disney theme park ride premiered
pirates of the caribbean the curse of
the black pearl you may have heard of it
it's heavy while many younger children
are unlikely to have seen that 2003 film
adults may get a sense of deja vu when
watching jungle cruise due to the fact
that the film's supernatural storyline
largely overlaps with that of the
earlier movie much like the pirates who
were cursed with eternal life after they
took the wrong treasure
the conquistadors who went after the
tears of the moon and jungle cruise were
cursed with eternal life
for attempting to take that treasure
inevitably just like captain barbosa and
his crew and pirates
aguirre and his allies wished to break
their immortal bonds if that weren't
enough the mid-movie revelation that
frank himself is also cursed with an
ending life because 400 years ago he was
a gorey's map maker
parallels the eventual revelation in
pirates that jack sparrow isn't dead
because he was the captain of the black
pearl before barboza
and his crew mutinied the resemblance
between the jungle cruise and pirates
mythology may raise some adults eyebrows
not to mention make them wonder why the
powers that be at disney felt the need
to include a supernatural plot line in a
film
based on a ride that's unlike pirates
never included anything that could be
interpreted as supernatural
jungle cruise nods to several well-known
films only adults are likely to notice
in addition to virus of the caribbean
there are hat tips to 1999's the mummy
the indiana jones films and romancing
the stone however if there's one classic
that especially influenced the new film
it's 1951's the african queen theme bug
buffs will know the jungle cruise homage
to the humphrey bogart and catherine
hepburn led classic is no accident
walt disney was partially inspired to
create the jungle cruise attraction in
disneyland by the african queen
given that connection it's not
surprising that the new movie bears a
noticeable resemblance to the older film
both have a plot that revolves around a
skipper becoming involved with a brother
and sister who require passage down a
waterway during world war one
my brother and i are looking for passage
up river please go away
i have a lot of money the african queen
influence can also be seen in the
dynamic between
frank and lily who constantly butt heads
only to come to respect and then fall
for one another
just like bogart and hepburn's
characters adults who notice a
connection between the two films may use
it as an opportunity to introduce their
kids to the 1951 classic
while disney has attempted to be more
inclusive by incorporating more openly
gay characters and films like the
live-action remakes of beauty and the
beast and cruella
it's done so in such a subtle way that
plenty of people wouldn't even notice
unfortunately jungle cruise has the same
issue the film includes perhaps the most
overtly out character yet in the form of
lily's close obsessed brother mcgregor
however it tiptoes lightly around the
issue of his sexuality
toward the middle of the film mcgregor
confesses to frank that although he
doesn't share his sister's belief in the
legend of the tears of the moon
he stinks by lily because unlike
everyone else in his life she didn't
abandon him when she learned about his
sexuality
however the whole story is told through
implication while adults will likely
pick up on what mcgregor is saying
his wording is vague enough that many
kids are unlikely to realize what
exactly he's even talking about
in the film's third act lily is forced
to swim for the first time
after frank finds an underwater chamber
with a lever in it that will lead them
to the tears of the moon
what kids and even some adults may not
realize is that when frank kisses lily
for the first time while she's trapped
underwater
it's not for any romantic reason after
all given the pairs will they or won't
they dynamic throughout the story
the kids can easily be interpreted as
the characters finally admitting their
feelings for one another
however that's not frank's intention as
he pandermines he's simply trying to
provide lily with air so she can stay in
the water long enough to pull the
chamber's lever
of course even adults would be justified
in interpreting frank as having
something of an ulterior motive here
especially since the exchange of oxygen
between the characters
looks more like a smooch than
mouth-to-mouth resuscitation
kids who have been lucky enough to visit
a disney park may pick up on some of the
film's direct references to the jungle
cruise ride
when frank goes under a makeshift
waterfall early in the film and
triumphantly introduces the backside of
water with a declaration that it's the
8th wonder of the world
everyone familiar with the ride will
smile knowingly however there are some
less obvious nods to the attraction that
kids may miss
including a shocking number of
ridiculous new puns and an early
reference to dr albert force
the man the ride's waterfall is
supposedly named after
the rocks you see here in the river are
sandstone but
some people just take them for granted
plus when frank is first introduced to
guiding a jungle cruise of tourists down
the amazon
he essentially functions as a skipper in
the theme park ride
as as bose continues along the water
it's revealed that frank has rigged up
his own makeshift jungle cruise
attraction
complete with a fake hippo in order to
provide the same thrilling and silly
experience as the ride disney parks fans
adore
it's one of my bolder attractions
interestingly after delays to the
coronavirus pandemic jungle cruise is
hitting theaters just as disneyland
opened an updated version of the ride
and the revised experience no longer
includes characters that are featured in
the film
after years of complaints over the
attractions depiction of native people
disneyland removes some of the audio
animatronic characters that appear
toward the end of the ride
including trader sam who was willing to
exchange two of his shrunken heads for
one of yours
the updated ride also excites a group of
headhunters who are characterized as
savages and throw spears at the right
vehicle
yet jungle cruise features both agenda
swaps trader sam
and a group of supposedly threatening
indigenous people
while the story avoids shading into
racism by revealing that the natives
behavior is all just part of a scheme
cooked up with frank to make his jungle
cruises more exciting
adults who keep up on disney parks news
will know that these references to the
ride
are now things of the past well i look
forward to disappointing you
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one